all right my name is rod ferguson and
i'm the chair of women's gender
sexuality studies
it's my pleasure to welcome you to our
2022 brethner event this is a very
special
moment for us because this is the first
time that we've had it since the
lockdown
the brudner prize established in 2000 is
awarded annually to an accomplished
scholar artist or activist whose work
has made significant
contributions to lgbt studies and lgbt
communities all right we have uh decided
to pluralize that this evening with the
panel
um and tonight's panelists certainly fit
that description our event is named
after james brodner who was an aids
activist urban planner
journalist and photographer
a man of wit and compassion outsized
knowledge and curiosity brudner valued
both academic inquiry and direct action
he spent 12 years as a policy analyst
for the city of new york
he also earned an m.a in journalism from
new york university and wrote for
various publications on gay and
aids-related topics
he became a member of act up the
treatment action group and other
organizations after the death of his
twin brother eric of aids in 1987.
he worked on treatment and prevention
issues with the national institutes of
health
pharmaceutical corporations and federal
agencies
in his final years he devoted much of
his time to traveling the back roads of
rural america with a camera
la mama gallery in new york mounted an
exhibition
of his photographs in 1997. he died of
age-related illness on september 18th
1998 at the age of 37.
through his will he established the
brudner prize
at yale as a quote perpetual annual
prize in quote for scholarship and
activism on gay and lesbian history and
contemporary experience
our thanks go first to the broadner
executors stephen carlin michael cormier
and ben pesner also we'd like to thank
the
wwgss staff ellen cooper
mo gardner keith geriac
and linda aurelia for the support that
they offered
our thanks also to rick leone from yale
broadcast center for av support
our thanks also go to the lgbt studies
committee
made up of jill richards the committee
chair
joe fachelle scott herring
and gretel floor
particularly we want to thank joe for
organizing tonight's panel
joe who is the author of screw consent
a better politics of sexual justice and
sex and harm in the age of consent
will introduce the panelists please
welcome joe fishel
[Applause]
okay
hi everyone and thank you rod
uh
great so yeah thank you welcome to the
blood nerd um i'm gonna keep my comments
short
and then i will introduce the speakers
and the introductions will also be short
uh i apologize that i'm going to lift my
introductions right from the program
that you are holding which we lifted
from their websites so
but the point of keeping it short is
that you can hear them and not me
um
so
uh before the question i will soon pose
to our panelists uh is anchored by two
or
might we could think of as anchored by
two geopolitical phenomena the first
russia's war against ukraine
and even the most materialist
intersectional feminist scholar
wonders sometimes
isn't all of that sex and gender stuff
superfluous or epiphenomenal to the
brutality and violence of war
of course uh many scholars and some
scholars in this room uh have
uh have
wrote written about the implication of
war making war legitimation and
insistent normativity around sex and
gender uh many have pointed out uh
russian officials and pundits how
russian officials and pundits have drawn
on gayness gender non-normativity uh as
threats to russia russian civilization
uh and children in particular
uh to authorize russian aggression
and its arrogation of power
so the uh second anchor point uh maybe a
surprise to nobody
um uh we could take the anxiety
generating we could take anxiety
generating stock
uh of the dem of the legislative attack
on women
girls and women queer kids and trans
kids
an attack ever more vicious and lethal
against girls women and queer and trans
kids minoritized along other axes of
inequality race class citizenship status
if commentators note uh the rhetorics of
gender and sexual normativity that
scaffold russian authoritarianism
we might observe how anti-gay anti-trans
and anti-women legislation
arrests extraordinary regulatory
surveillance and punitive power into the
hands of our legislators
so a thought behind the question what is
sexual justice
is how to think those phenomena and
those dangers together
even as the scale of our scholars
answers
will travel from the couple form to the
planetary
so that's kind of all i've got by way of
scaffolding
i'm going to introduce our speakers and
kind of more formally ask them to ask
them this question
um so i would just left we're bigger
okay so uh paisley cora is a professor
of political science and women in gender
studies
at brooklyn college and the graduate
center of cuny
uh professor kara has written widely on
transgender issues including on topics
such as discrimination and sex
reclassification and the transgender
rights movement
he is the author and editor of over 30
articles and books and co-founder of the
leading journal in transgender studies
tsq transgender studies quarterly
crora's newest book sex is there's a
typo here sex is a sex does governing
transgender identity will be uh released
in the spring of 2022 by nyu press i
should say that uh my lecture gender
justice power institutions had the
extraordinary opportunity to read
professor croz some of professor cross
book and also uh text of our other uh
panelists today um which has been
fantastic
um jay gossett is the racial justice
post-doctoral fellow
initiative for a just society at the
center for contemporary critical thought
at columbia university jay gossett is a
black non-binary femme writer there will
be a visiting scholar at the center for
life writing at wolfson college oxford
university in 2022-23
gossett was a 2019-2020 helena
rubenstein fellow in critical studies in
the whitney independent study program as
well as a 2020-2021 graduate fellow at
the center for cultural analysis at
rutgers university
they also co-edited with professor david
getzey i love david casey they uh co-ed
professor david getzi uh a syllabus on
trans and non-binary methods for art
journal which just recently received the
2022 caa journal award
uh tay meadow associate professor of
sociology at columbia university tenured
like last week so yay
um uh professor meadows associate
professor of sociology at columbia uh
her research in writing on gender
sexuality and intimacy centers deep
ethnographic immersion and in-depth
interviewing she's the author of trans
kids being gendered in the 21st century
and co-editor of other please specify
queer methods in sociology
as well as numerous scholarly titles she
is currently completing a new
ethnographic book tentatively titled
edge play the erotic life of social
difference
uh shatima threadcraft associate
professor of gender and sexuality
studies philosophy and political science
at vanderbilt university
professor threadcraft is the author of
intimate justice the black female body
and the body politic
which is the winner of the national
women's studies association
sarah h whaley award for the best book
on women and labor the 2017 w.e.b du
bois distinguished book award from the
national conference of black political
scientists and finally the 2017 best
book award for the american political
science association's race ethnicity and
politics organized section it's an
awesome book
so those are my introductions
and i will leave with the question
what is sexual justice what does sexual
justice demand institutionally
politically ethically and aesthetically
how do we envision sexual justice within
and across activisms and intimacies
inside and beside pandemic life
so uh we will start with che gusset and
go down the row also there's lots of
like snacks and coffee so make sure you
get that at the end of the event okay
i'll turn it over to you cool
[Applause]
uh thank you so much
uh joe and
to rod
and to the amazing
um co
brudner roundtable panelists it's such
an honor to be here um and
especially someone who's been reading
your
individual and collective work for for
many years um i appreciate this
invitation uh to think through this
question of um
sexual justice
uh so
so i'm just gonna
be reading and thinking through
sexual justice through the aesthetic
through art
through black trans art in the afterlife
of slavery and
hopefully during the
kind of q a can talk through some of
the cardinal points or orientation
points that you brought up joe that kind
of anchor this this conversation
so
i want to open with a quote by corten
spillers
in order to name the black woman and the
sexual
the investigator is obliged to back all
the way up to that suspenseful chapter
in the unfolding of subjecthood
which begins for africanity in the west
not with a body which one sees well
enough
but with that with with which that body
was made to mean with what that body was
made to mean via the powerful grammars
of capture
building on black feminist and
literature professor horton spiller's
theoretical articulation of grammars of
capture
my work considers how great these
grammars function as the political
vernacular through which cultural
regimes are both rehearsed and renewed
i examine aesthetic objects and
cinematic interventions made by black
radical queer and trans performers and
artists and writers
and how these interventions
perform a deconstruction of the what she
calls the grammars of capture
and the carceral metaphysics of the
subject by marshalling fugitive forms of
aesthetics and untraditional archives
so in this brief
talk or segment i think through the work
of my sibling the trans art black trans
artist tourmaline
and how she engages in what sadia
hartman terms critical fabulation
in resistance to the aesthetic and
racial regime of the archive of slavery
at the same time in resistance to the
normative and neoliberal politics of
what today we
call transvisibility in our contemporary
moment
black trans historical figures are
fugitive to the terms of the official
archive except in moments of
criminalization
when they appear through the register of
the police record or the court
transcript
which is where the 1836 case of mary
jones
enters into the realm of historical
legibility and visibility
i first encounter the historical figure
of mary jones
in tavia nyong'o who is here who does
amazing work in his uh text amalgamation
waltz
and like any proper archivist i
immediately rushed to order the court
transcript jones was arrested in 1836
she was a sex worker in new york city
she
was brought into court
sensationalized through like a
lithograph that circulated went viral
for this early age of print media
and also
was interrogated for her gender uh in
the courtroom and it was the spectac
spectacle and political theater
and so in the courtroom she's asked you
know who t who taught you to dress this
way and she replies defiantly
i've always dressed this way amongst
people of my own
color
um
and so that always is really profound in
terms of thinking about black trans
temporalities and existence and
resistance
so in uh salacia tourmaline's film
uh about mary jones which is an
aesthetic mediation and critical
fabulation of her biography jones is
played by
actor rowan amon who's pictured here
tourmaline's work moves in the liminal
space between the historical record of
black trans life as well as the realm of
the magical
it is black queer and trans speculation
part of an aesthetic legacy and
genealogy in the tradition of octavia
butler who rod is gracing our presence
within his
t-shirt
uh chip delaney and also the milieu of
such films insurgent aesthetics of such
films as born in flames that guides the
optics of salacia
the short film takes place in seneca
village
a putatively free black enclave that was
eventually destroyed showing the ruse of
black property ownership property itself
or of objects
and it was raised to erect what is now
central park
and that happened in the 1850s
shalatia dramatizes the intramural
tensions that cut across and through the
black community a community rendered
always already under duress by slave
catchers in the north
as well as the what frank wilderson
calls the emergency of civil society
itself
a black abolitionist peter dermott runs
both a free press and a boarding house
and watches with disdain out the window
as jones engages in illicit sex work and
trade with white men outside
the intramural then is not without its
fractures and visions
man monster posters surround the city
which actually happened uh in the
historical record and these lithographs
are pasted to walls and trees signifying
that jones is wanted
the entire community is also subject
always to imminent capture
jones situation there is both the
collective and intramural one but also
the particular predicament of black
trans fugitivity
dermot disapproves of jones immorality
and vice but still provides her refuse
refuge in the version of the film
installed at the brooklyn museum which
was this amazing kind of 50th
anniversary exhibition
um uh commemorating stonewall
title nobody promised you tomorrow uh
which is was a marsha p johnson
quote
we see
the glimpse of a glimmer of an affair
while dermott judges
jones for her carnal sins of the flesh
he is not respected by his uh is not
protected by respectability
the police storm his home looking for
jones showing that black life is never
safe or protected and that autonomy is
always a quality of whiteness as bodily
and communal
sovereignty they threatened to close
down his entire establishment jones goes
on the run fugitive she is cornered
traps resists fights but is overpowered
and arrested
she knows magic however and this is part
of a kind of uh ode to or um
kind of enactment of uh
black cosmology cosmological and african
indigenous traditions so she uses magic
to try time travel
to the present which
is also part of a black speculative
imaginary of 19th century fiction
and slave narratives like freda douglas
narrative where he gets a magical amulet
um from his friend sandy that he says is
part of the kind of gave him power to
overthrow
master kobe
so in this film jones uses water as a
transport and moves through in between
time allowing her to escape the confines
of her jail cell
and in doing so she violates the laws of
physics and moves queerly or what tavia
nyong'o might call anger in an angular
fashion across the entanglement of
space-time so in some ways the film is
about what daphne brooks calls
escapology
and she uses uh she escapes she manages
to escape one one version of capture the
pre-emancipation past only to be
kind of land to land in another which
would be the the anti-black president of
central park
tourmaline's film
asks us to consider the ways in which
anti-black and anti-trans temporalities
are insufficient for black trans freedom
and how the world remains a grammar of
capture
the firm raises questions about sexual
justice and fugitivity
and the condition of black trans
existence beyond the racialized and
anti-trans world
and so i want to end with some questions
what might happen in the realm of the
aesthetic which is disallowed and
foreclosed in the realm of the political
where does the aesthetic begin and the
political end
black literary and aesthetic practices
have historically been a spear in an
arena where the political and its
representative functions racial
liberalism slash democracy are left
aside for alternative imaginaries or
where strict the strict boundaries
between the two dissolve in their
interplay so thinking about tony
morrison's beloved to sutton griggs
fictional imagining of a sovereign black
state
so in both fiction and non-fiction
these instead become
areas or genres where political
experimentation
happens and where justice to come is
staged
and in silesia the philosophical edifice
of justice emerges from a vantage point
of the runaway slave the radical ethics
of the slave that aims for what motin
and harney
emphatically say
charge or demand the abolition of a
society that could even
have prisons
it's itself and so therefore abolition
is an unfinished and open invitation to
an emancipatory project that's both
interior and exterior perennial as well
and so i think i guess for just to close
you know i feel curious about the the
political grammar of sexual
justice given that justice is often
part of a grammar of legal capture
and incommensurable you know justice and
the law are
often collapsed into each other and
conflated
but
of course there you know from walter
benjamin to daredevil to martin luther
king jr we learn all about
there's a whole wealth of
kind of study
that thinks about the incommensurability
of justice and the law and so
i wonder about the the grammar of sexual
justice and
perhaps maybe if there might be ways to
imagine
a new political grammar beyond the idea
of justice itself which kind of carries
a baggage
that's all about like
reconciliation
restitution
two sides that come into kind of a
cosmic balance and so i guess i have
that
left as an open question for us to all
consider together thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
okay
okay thank you
okay
can you hear me
okay so
i want to thank professor fischel for
the invitation it's great to be here and
among such uh great scholars
uh what is sexual justice
so since i wrote
my book intimate justice and the north
american
necropolitics and gender that professor
fischell students read
i've learned a great deal from black
feminists sovereign queer and trans
abolitionists namely from beth ritchie
dana milian nick estes and melanie
yazzie kathy cohen eric stanley dean
spade miriam caba and andrea richie so
i've learned about the role of police
not only in enforcing gender normativity
policing gender and gender expression
but also in the disproportionate
interpersonal violence that black women
experience
so my book and the article i think
focused on intimate interpersonal
violence and really on that as opposed
to state violence and these authors as
well as activist formations including in
sight and cabba's survived and punished
have helped me to see more clearly
something like intimate state violence
so that includes the role of police and
policing as well as well as a broader
tough on crime approach in perpetuating
violence against women particularly
black women who violate gender norms
though black women violate gender norms
by their existence in some sense
now but also uh in esc not only in
perpetuating the violence but in
escalating the interpersonal violence
gender-based violence that they
experience
now my current research
uh looks at the politics of black death
and how black politics from
lynching to the movement for black lives
has centered spectacular death
this presents a problem for black women
who are less likely to be killed and
spectacular in the spectacular ways that
cis black men are
men are more likely to be killed in
public generally by acquaintances in
strangers and in the era inaugurated by
the rodney king beating more likely to
have the violence and death that they
experienced filmed and circulated
women on the other hand are more likely
to be killed in private by intimates and
because of intimacy this is often even
the case when black women are killed by
police so andrea ricci states that
police brutality against black women
takes place inside the home and is often
unseen as a result so here brianna
taylor's death echoes the deaths of many
black women whose names we're now called
upon to say including eleanor bumpers
ayanna stanley jones tatiana jefferson
catherine johnson charlena lyles and
pearly golden
so much of the violence takes place
inside the home in welfare offices
patrol cars or even in precincts as
women attempt to report intimate partner
violence
a significant portion of the violence
happens when black and other
marginalized women ask for help in their
intimate relationships
so on the violence and death that occurs
at the intersection of the war on drugs
and the sphere of intimate relations as
was the case with taylor
so a warrant was issued for taylor's
arrest because of her association her
intimacy with her former partner and
she's now dead
here no knock warrants themselves
continued this country's brutal and
often deadly regulation of the black
intimate sphere
now as the organization and i say as the
organization survived and punished
co-founded by the incomparable
miriam caba
abolitionist organizer
this organization argues effectively
that jails and prisons and not rape
crisis centers and women's shelters
actually represent our collective
institutional response to the problem of
gender-based violence against black and
other marginalized women
so the aclu estimates that almost 60
percent of
people in women's prisons worldwide are
survivors of violence and at some
prisons this number is as high as 94
now i want to be clear to mark the
distinction between sex and sexual
violence here though i also want to be
clear that women are experiencing sexual
violence in this institutional context
because they are in intimate
relationships and have had sex
i want to mark the fact that black women
are being murdered killed severely hurt
and punished ultimately because they
have had sex and this creates
significant political and organizational
problems
but my research looks not only at this
aspect but also at what i've
come to call black women's death work
so here women like ida b wells
maybe bradley that is emmett till's mom
and clementine barfield of detroit's
save our sons and daughters also known
as so sad
which is an organization of the mothers
of murdered children founded in the
1980s and connected to our current error
and its own politics of death as trayvon
martin's mother contacted sosa's
philadelphia chapter they were among the
first to bring attention to the death of
her son
so each of these women made
transformational contributions to the
black counter public sphere and their
entry into that public sphere was
authorized by a man's death
now the subtitle for my uh
section on madame wells is wells and the
empirical miracle and i talk about how
she constructs a black truth apparatus
from broken white parts and she's the
first to use a lynching photo in
anti-lynching work a strategy that we
know will be repeated for years to come
but she also commissions a portrait of
herself
with her murdered friend thomas moss's
family
and lee rayford says that this
represents her important expansion of
the lynching photo genre bringing the
family left behind into the frame of
anti-lynching activism now
i'm in the process
of writing
the section on bar feeling so sad and i
could literally go on for hours about
them but let me just say that the
organization was extraordinary so two
weeks after one of her sons was killed
and another gravely injured in an act of
teen violence barfield organized a
meeting for families affected by
violence against children and teens the
resulting organization became according
to youth violence expert and former
assistant dean of harvard school of
public health deborah protro stiff
a quote model for community-based
activism for organizing for the rest of
the country so sad will go on to have an
impact on national conversations
regarding youth violence and at its peak
receive requests for organizing help
from milwaukee st louis atlanta los
angeles san francisco columbus and omaha
chapters were started in flint michigan
fresno birmingham alabama st louis and
st louis
and i told you about the philadelphia
chapter which is was the largest and
perhaps most important
now they ran a grief support group
for the mothers of murder children
the support group would expand to
include a family support group a male
grief support group a child counseling
group a survivors of violence group
they ran a 24 hour crisis hotline and
provided mental health services for
children who hurt they organized a
crisis intervention team that went into
schools churches and door-to-door
neighborhoods after area deaths they had
a speaker's bureau a monthly newsletter
with columns by barfield and james boggs
a weekly radio show they kick-started
the urban gardening movement with their
harvesting program and they even
organized in prisons
now members of the organization held an
explicit theory of what allowed violence
to proliferate in the community and that
was the seating of public state space
so barfield would say instead of hiding
behind bar doors and windows we can and
must march
out of our homes and our churches and
begin walking the streets in large and
small groups
making clear to everyone young and old
that we are reclaiming our communities
looking out for each other and saving
our sons and daughters
earlier in the same column
farfield would say every time one of our
sons and daughters is killed we must
march we must hold candlelight vigils we
must create people's memorials to show
that we care we must not allow darnell
byrd gary irwin and otis haley or any of
our lost loved ones to be turned into
faceless statistics on street corners
like joy and evergreen we must paint
their portraits to remind us that each
one of them was someone's son
someone's brother someone's friend
we have to physically plant ourselves
she said and she would make reference to
trees a lot
at the scene of every shooting or
homicide in our neighborhood we must
make hope visible our children need to
see with their own eyes in the midst of
devastation that people are standing
together and struggling for a better
world
but this was not all right so she says
we have to organize to rebuild our
communities everyone can do something we
can march against the crack house on our
block we can develop
treatment programs we can transform
vacant lots into community gardens and
children's parks where kids can play
together
we can work towards creating small
businesses to provide jobs we can
organize block parties and festivals to
celebrate the positive achievements of
youth
now justice then was not about
punishment but the work of building a
better world justice for the women's
dead children was bringing about an end
to death worlds and creating life worlds
in their place
communing however with deaf children
death world dead children even as they
build these life worlds
so significantly they had a much more
sophisticated understanding of the
causes of violence and at times an
implicit
but often explicit critique of the war
on drugs and the carceral state approach
to violence
additionally they embraced a form of
community accountability that i that is
endorsed by contemporary abolitionists
so melinda price who's written on the
organization says
through their relationship with their
children both dead and living and here
price is referring to what she is
calling the afterlife of black
motherhood where these organizations uh
or organized mothers of murder murder
children continue to parent their
children by creating nurturing
communities for kids amidst the violence
and destruction of urban abandonment in
the war on drugs that is life worlds in
the midst of death worlds but price
continues they crafted public roles to
solve complex problems at its roots in
this sense their analysis was more
complex and astute than the analysis
that informed any government program
they understood that solving the problem
of violence against and among black
children meant surrounding them with
love building healthy self-esteem and
finding meaningful work for teenagers on
the cusp of adulthood
so
i'm thinking about the relationship
between wells till bradley and
barfield's death work for racial justice
and the death work that must be done for
the women who die because they have had
sex today
now someone pointed out the difference
in the public's acceptance of grief in
public for the mothers of a murdered
child
and their life will life world creating
grief in public
and
the difference between that right
and
grief in public for women who've had sex
and i think this is an important point
but as i've thought about it i realized
that price reminds us that at the time
of sosad's work the predominant
understandings of the black woman the
black mother was the welfare queen and
the crack fiend so these women had no
easy road to hope
and perhaps the gap between these two
archetypes archetypes is not as far
apart as you might think
in any case just this week i became
struck by the similarity of barfield and
cabba's theory of what justice demands
so across three to four decades they
seem to have come to the same conclusion
and you may or may not be surprised to
learn that it aligns with the
conclusions of iris marin young that
justice requires participation
participatory democracy that we cannot
create something good with which we are
not all involved in making
so institutionally the tough on crime
approach must end for there to be sexual
justice but we must all be involved in
the creating of institutions
i can't say what i think sexual justice
will look like
like bar field and cabba i believe that
we all have to say that collectively
together and i do believe that like them
we can't have it if we abdicate our
collective responsibility for providing
sexual safety for us all but i do think
that it will involve all of us creating
life worlds of the kind that barfield's
organization attempted to do thank you
all right i'm gonna stand up but i i
don't have any slides but i thought i'd
stand so
um
okay so i'm talking about sexual justice
and i'm taking sexual
down to its
its root sex
and by sex i mean sex as an m or f or x
not as sex as in having sex so
that's my sex part the justice i think
we'll cover we'll get to around the end
so but one other short note on language
um
many people would use gender to talk
about
the marks or driver's license and the
passports and so on but i use the word
sex and let me explain why
this is the thing i can either see you
or i can see my paper so i think i'll
see my paper then you're all blurry oh
well
folks here
okay
so most
a lot a lot of my work is focused on how
state actors define the word sex or
decide who's m or who's f or who's f x
um and i am not interested in evaluating
evaluating the correctness of different
claims to deciding on who's m or f f or
x so what i do is i look at what
different definitions make possible so i
don't know what sex is i don't know the
right thing is i'm just like let's see
what a definition but that this
government agency puts forward that's
backed by the force of law force of law
what effects that has so
so
i use gender though i still use the word
gender but i refer to
by gender i i refer to like shared
though often contested norms narratives
practices and conventions that arrange
bodies identities
roles and expressions and hierarchies of
difference based on binary notions of
male and female masculine feminine
and so on so just a little
introduction
so in the last month
supreme court nominee katan katanji
brown jackson was castigated by a
republican
senator for refusing to define the word
women woman in her nomination hearings a
week later the binding administration
announced that individuals will have the
option of choosing x as the gender
marker on their passport i should say
sex markers right
so it's quite a weird moment or act um
though the right and the left are like
bitterly divided by the left i mean the
good left not the my kind of left not
the old lefty boys who don't like trans
people whether the right and the left
are um are brutally divided over the
rights of transgender people activists
on both sides agree on one thing
if their side can win the battle of how
society as a whole defines a person's
sex
americans will be forced to either give
up
discriminate against trans people or be
allowed to continue to discriminate
against trans people so it's like the
way that rhetoric kind of
moves around it's as if the fate of the
republic depends in no small measure on
the outcome of the battle over sex
definition
but this note this kind of this
notion of a kind of manichaean battle
between the sexes however rests on a
upon a rest on a dramatically mistaken
view of how state federal and local
governments approach the issue of
deciding a person's sex
whether it's on a birth certificate a
driver's license a marriage certificate
whether it's in a prison a homeless
shelter a school bathroom
historically government agencies have
been far less interested in social
conventions about what sex is whether
it's biological biological assignment at
birth
uh gender identity as an adult and so on
they're less interested in the perfect
the perfect definition in some abstract
platonic way than what than what sex
does for that agency's mission so
officials in prison for example define
sex differently than do officials in the
department of motor vehicles even when
those officials work in the same
jurisdiction of a single city or state
so sex classifications radically depend
in ways that few journalists
and many and scholars and politicians
recognize except we do because we're in
this world
sex classifications depend on what a
government agency is trying
to do so i want to kind of illustrate
this by telling a story of new york city
and i'm the kid at the thanksgiving
dinner table who like
started to tell a story and by the time
i got to the end no was paying attention
so you know in my 50s i'm still like
maybe i can tell a story but here i have
a microphone and you know you probably
won't interrupt me but i'm gonna try to
try to tell a story and not um not mess
up any punch lines so
um in the 1960s trans people were going
to the city and saying hey will you
change our birth certificates and the
city was like i don't know that's weird
so they did it a few times and after a
while they were like i'm not sure this
is a good idea so they asked a bunch of
doctors should we change their birth
certificates the doctors met two or
three times and they were like
no
because if you let them change their
budget advocates they might commit a
fraud upon the public
and um
uh by like marrying some unsuspecting
person their their image was of a trans
woman marrying an unsuspecting cisgender
man who would you know accidentally get
rid to a trans woman so they wouldn't
change it then the 1970s i think it was
the aclu or the new york civil liberties
union um
trying to get the city to change its
policy and the city did it said okay
this is a weird issue you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna give you new
birth certificates but we're going to
take the box of for um that indicates
sex off there's no box whatsoever so
everybody else has a box that says mrf
on trans people's birth certificates
people were born the city there's no box
which isn't great for people who have
presented business advocates because
people who look at birth certificates
all day
say well this is a trans person because
there's no box here but anyways it was
something
but by the 2000s new york city think of
itself as very progressive thought okay
that we're a little behind you know in
the 70s this might have been a cool
policy but now this is behind so they
kind of convened a committee and this is
where i come into it as like a an expert
but probably more of an advocate
actually um
the kavita committee to decide like okay
what should the right policy be for uh
for for uh
letting people change their their sex
mark on their birth certificate so they
had trans health care advocates
transgender rights advocates they had
surgeons they had psychiatrists
um
um and of the people who were not on the
city's payroll so some of the people
were city officials but the people who
weren't on the city's payroll
most everybody worked hard to convince
policy makers to drop the requirement
for any kind of surgical or medical
intervention the only people who didn't
work for the city who wanted to keep a
surgical requirement were
surgeons they thought that was a good
metric for changing people's sex the
good thing is they made so much money in
private practice coming to a meeting
cost them a lot of money was presumed so
they only came to one meeting so that
was actually quite quite helpful
um
but we kind of made the usual argument
transition is an individualized process
and gender identity not genitals should
determine sex classification and
initially the board of health which is
the group we were working with agreed to
adopt this recommendation
but then they shocked it around other
city agencies
and the other city agencies said no this
is a terrible policy we don't agree
and our proposal was shelved
uh for some years so we decided the
advocates on the committee decided that
this is just plain transphobic this is
like not okay this is just mean um we
you know we would talk about the harms
that people face when there is a
mismatch between the m or the f
on a person's identity papers and their
gender identity
um
there's a great quote one woman who
testified to the city official said she
says i don't suffer from gender
dysphoria i suffer from bureaucratic
dysphoria you know she kind of talks
about the problem is the state's problem
um so that's like very powerful and i i
was there when that statement was made
but one thing that that my thinking has
shifted on this is that focusing on the
harm to transgender people that these
decisions make
actually in some sense makes it hard to
see what the city was doing
like
and what their reasoning was
it just seemed transphobic but as a few
years later i was doing some research i
came across some material provided a
different perspective so back in the 60s
when the new york city was trying to
figure out what to do they wrote some
official in washington they said well
what do you do are you people at the
bureau of uh
statistics or somebody in the department
of health education and welfare
and the people the federal government
people wrote back and said you know we
we thought about this and i canvassed a
bunch of people from other departments
and we can provide you with no guidance
on the question he said since various
agencies carry out differing
responsibilities the problems which
confront them vary
the more we delved into the problem the
more ramifications that cropped up so
this for me who's like looking at sex
classification stuff is so fascinating
because they're basically talking about
how sex is an instrument of
governmentality though that's not the
language they're using um and not
talking about sex as in some kind of
abstract thing
um
so officials at some agencies like the
social security administration were
worried about identity management and
social security benefits they were right
at the selective service people were
worried all the different agencies were
like oh i'm not sure about this
so in other words there could be no
unified policy on the matter of sex
reclassification because each agency
would have to investigate the effects of
sex reclassification policies on its own
work and then back to the you know the
2005 policy that failed
um
a transgender rights group sued the city
they said this is not okay this is mean
um it said that requiring individuals to
have surgery uh before
their their gender their birth
certificate could be changed was
arbitrary capricious
discriminatory and otherwise unlawful
and then law which is boring but the law
it's like it's bad to be arbitrary and
capricious there's supposed to be a good
reason for things
um
so the advocates were drawing on medical
authorities to argue that sex markets on
identity documents should be consistent
with
the individual's gender identity during
all this like social science and medical
science
um so this the city's policy according
to advocates was irrational
and the response of the city's lawyers
kind of goes back to the response of
that federal official in the 1960s they
argued that the existence of different
approaches to sex classification does
not render an agency's rule irrational
for the city the rationality of each
agency's approach to sex classification
depended on what the agency did on its
remit not on what sex is in itself
so the
the debate on sex was taking place in
two different registers so the advocates
including myself we're thinking about
experts and truth and what how to really
think about what sex is
and the bureaucrats were thinking about
governing about like what a sex
classification would do to a prison or a
homeless shelter or a different agency
so
for the city how sex was defined
could be changed depending on agent uh
by agency by agency depending on the
need so i like to tell this story
because it shows how advocates including
myself
working on this issue
went into the process thinking the point
was degree on some right definition of
sex but it turned out that the city
bureaucrats and lawyers of the real
flukodians understand that sex was not a
thing in itself but something
instrumentalized differently by
different agencies
so
so much scholarship and advocacy has
been taken up with arguing that it's
unjust to use traditional ideas about
gender to require transgender people to
have surgery before changing their sex
classification or to prevent any changes
at all a lot of like that it's just
wrong and i agree with that it is wrong
but from these precincts we also hear
that sex and gender are so complicated
that the only workable solution is to
fix base sex classification on gender
identity i don't disagree with that
either
but the other assumption
that bad policies are the result of
transphobia and that good policies are
not doesn't help us understand how every
one of them fixes us in a place
implicates us in relation to state power
that might allow some reforms of sex
classification but draws our attention
away from the other half of the equation
state power so we spent a lot of time
denaturalizing sex but like we're not so
good at denaturalizing the state you
know what i mean we're like we've a lot
no one reads marx anymore you know i
mean maybe he's coming maybe he's
getting trendy reasonably but so the
proposition and i was doing this paper
this morning i was like boy like every
paper a political theorist ever presents
is really just another version of marx's
on the jewish question so i apologize
for that i guess that's the tradition i
meant but
but the proposition that sex is
manufactured in and through regulations
formal and informal policies judicial
decisions and legislative enactments
does not mean that we should see the
state as fixed in place
still and hard as a monument that sex is
an output doesn't mean that we should
black box the state like turn into a
thing that we don't look into its inner
doings
um
so before i conclude one last
one less word about the new york city
situation new york city now has a great
policy you can change it to f to m to x
you don't need a doctor's letter you
don't need any medical intervention
that's all really it's the perfect
policy
but um it's not like the city finally
agreed that sex really should be gender
identity it was because the new logic of
identity politics meant that the de
blasio administration
could give this
constituency what it wanted he said i
can give you the press release we're
getting transgender people what they
want but everybody else born in the city
still gets an mrnf
on their birth certificate so we're
still kind of trapped in this arithmetic
of identity politics of demands made and
demands met so to conclude
to return to the perilous moment in
which we find ourselves where we have
passage of legislation targeting trans
youth and those who care for them bills
including trans girls from sports don't
say gay bills the organized attack on
what's taken to be gender ideology i
mean that's more outside the united
states but
as scary as this moment is i see two
positive or exciting hopefully they're
exciting possibilities
first sex classification has always been
instrumentalized
um for the purposes of governance that's
we're already we've are already there
but what was previously a relatively
secretive internal decision of
government bureaucrats concerned with
the efficiency and effectiveness of
their agencies and particular state
projects
has very recently become a boisterous
public debate for the first time the
decision about gender identity has the
potential to be democratic not only
deliberated by the people but with the
interests and concerns of the people
most affected by those policies trans
people take it into account
second as we put the needs of
transgender people front and center in
deliberations about sex classification
it's also an opportunity to shine the
spotlight on the other side of this
mutually constitutive relationship the
governing opposite apparatuses that
determine what a livable life looks like
so we can get sex classification right
we can you know fight the democratic
public sphere for that
that's good but it's also important to
kind of point out like we can get
everybody's every jurisdictions every
agency's sex classification policy right
but the changes that would make
with improved the lives of the most
trans people are not those changes right
those changes would be having a public
public um having um
public health
national health care plan
prison abolition and like radically
reducing if not eliminating income
equality those were the things that
would change most people's lives
so as we contest the classifications the
exclusions from public life the attacks
the cps investigations
this is also a moment to turn the
spotlight not on sex but back to the
state and think about the very
architecture of justice that distributes
inequality so thank you
[Applause]
so i want to start by
thanking joe and gender studies for
inviting me to sit on this panel
alongside three people whose work is is
tremendously influential
both in my my prior book and and
particularly in some of what i'm working
on now um
so i'm the one who's going to talk about
sex because this is an lgbt studies
thing and
you know
it's it's time it's time we're going to
talk about we're going to talk about i'm
going to put the sex in sexual justice
um so i'm a micro sociologist which
means that i study
themes of intimacy recognition
from a kind of
perspective that foregrounds face to
face interaction and thinking through
the ways in which we live social
structures on in our most intimate lives
and moments
and so i'm going to be talking a little
bit today about what sexual justice
demands of us interpersonally
so for the last several years up until
kovid made it impossible i was
conducting ethnographic research in
several different bdsm communities now
i'm
guessing that that if you're at an lgbt
studies
talk this is not the first time you've
heard the term bdsm but when i talk
about it really what i'm focusing on is
sets of erotic practices and
and and emotional practices um
that
rely on a hierarchical organization of
power between uh people
and as i
began to do the writing of what will be
this ethnographic book i realized that a
lot of what i was learning was about the
erotic life of social difference how
differences between people related to
gender sexuality race class nationality
religion and age become activated even
electrified by the erotic brought into
focus crystallized in the moment now the
way sexuality makes gender turn
technicolor or uh makes racial
difference
animated how social roles anchored in
power like teacher student for example
which we were talking about at lunch
today
gather intense affect and usually we
think of these things in negative terms
right as structures of power underlying
bodily forms of violence like rape and
psychic forms of violence like sexual
racism
and these are you know deeply important
social pathologies
but
on some level i think it lets
non-violent sex off the hook
um by way of locating unjust sexuality
only in moments of non-consensual
violence right whether it's structural
or interpersonal
and so i want to focus on
two epistemological responses
to
uh sort of transgressive sexuality that
i think are complicit in this
exceptionalizing
of violence um in in non-consensual
forms of sexuality so the first is a
framework common in queer social and
psychoanalytic theory that positions
redemptive sexuality as anti-social
anti-rational and ego shattering to use
leo bersani's formulation
or the more popular often attributed to
feminist notion that sex is either
presumptively egalitarian and thus good
or it sits in relation to trauma as
either it's self-traumatic the cause of
trauma or a means of repairing it
and i want to offer two observations
from my work both of which are
preliminary see here's the thing about
doing empirical work if you really like
real people keep you kind of
intellectually honest in a certain way
and so i think that they're that they're
they're often a good place to start
right like when we're thinking about how
things work in the world so i want to i
want to say two things today first um i
want to argue for something that i'm
coming to call articulate intimacy which
one might even consider a hyper rational
orientation towards desire and pleasure
and second i'm going to suggest that we
think differently than queer theorists
often do about the connection between
pleasure and negative affect right um
that we think about ways to imagine
states beyond pleasure that facilitate
eroticized forms of intimacy that are
deeply grounded in social location
so bdsm is what sociologists call an
extreme case of intimate relation
in the sense that we view it as deviant
or exceptional in the sense that we have
a sense that this is not what most
people do but bdsm is also as ariana
cruz writes an aperture through which to
view some of the architecture of the
sexual order more generally so in my
travels through bdsm subcultures i met
people who engaged in various forms of
psychological and erotic play that
traffic in social difference
race play rape play nazi play these are
some examples and in my conversations
with these practitioners women and
people of color had extremely articulate
relationships to their play particularly
those who occupy the minoritarian
positions in erotic encounters with
others
men and white people of all genders
struggled
more with articulating their investments
or individual level experiences with
reproducing most particularly racialized
domination in their play and i began
thinking about the inarticulateness of
whiteness as perhaps
one of the biggest barriers to sexual
justice on the diatic level and this is
different from you know what we hear
about on npr
when they're talking about white
fragility right which is a state of kind
of collapse into defensiveness or anger
at the challenge of racial
accountability right this is a failure
of cultural language for attempting not
merely accountability but an accounting
for
uh the racialized nature of all of our
desires
so
um
this wasn't this wasn't only um the case
for my subjects this is true of dominant
queer theory as well i'm thinking of the
work of tim dean david halper and leo
burssani and others
mostly coming from white gail may gay
male perspectives and some newer work in
psychoanalysis that foregrounds the
dissolution of the self in the act of
sex um
and
as as kind of like the redemptive
potential of of transgressive sexuality
um
it's a kind of and and there's a there's
a whole train of thought in sociology as
well that that has a kind of um
fantastical notion of the sexual uh and
sexual communities as as space as spaces
that are acutely amenable to
transcending social difference right on
the other hand black feminist writing by
ariana cruz amber mooser jennifer nash
and others
describes a form of black and brown
jewish sons that comes from a highly
racialized affect from attending to the
pleasures that are possible by taking
seriously the legacies of trauma and
rupture that define the current racial
moment
even by using negative affect not to
efface the self but to confront it more
deeply and honestly than the sexual
terrain of egalitarian
egalitarianism allows and i say this not
as a judgment of my white subjects as
individuals many of whom were engaged in
earnest efforts toward accountability in
their intimate lives and indeed bdsm in
its ideal form at least in the
communities that i studied is itself a
form of articulate intimacy by which i
mean it is a form of relationship to
others that has a meta-narrative about
itself that accounts for specific
articulations of power that exist within
a structure of accountability that
ensures not merely consent but a
specific forms of self-reflection
the problem is that there were few
linguistic conventions for people to
draw on for formulating racialized
desires outside of tropes of color
blindness objectification or exclusion
so some use the sexual to find new
grammars some means of encounter that
coalesce outside of language ways of
eroticizing in the body what can be so
difficult to narrate interpersonally
so
i really struggled with deciding what
anecdote from my field work to share
with you in the brief moments that i
have for this provocation and so i
scrolled through my rolodex of favorite
perverts the upper east side
it's really it's getting bigger every
minute
the upper east side heterosexual jewish
couple who enjoyed nazi play on shabbat
the black white lesbian couple married
for 20 years who engaged in practices of
objectification and the iconography of
slavery the normcore couple who
maintained a 1950s household the
american and eastern european couple who
did mail order bride play
or the time i was invited to participate
in an interrogation scene by a
well-known black female dominant
all would have led me to kind of the
same set of conclusions that even in a
context of acute attunement to power
social differences produce what
rachel gorman calls a quagmire of affect
a hazardous terrain of inarticulate or
invisible whiteness that over determines
what we know how to think
what we know how we know to feel and
what we are able to say
people of color
who i interviewed explicitly understood
and and women as well either gendered or
racialized play as either reformatting
objectification into recognition
reversing the terms of subjectification
by either consenting to it and thus not
fully being
an object but in fact being a subject of
it
repeating it to gain mastery or spinning
the iconography to subjectify
either maleness or whiteness
they tied it to emotional states like
fear aggression grief shame humiliation
but always in context with the very
specificity of their identities and
indeed bdsm identities themselves
often merge sexual practices
uh with orientations to their an
individual's particular constellation of
gender racial and sexual identification
so sociologists have written um a lot
about how you know the sort of
contemporary moment is a moment of
specialized erotic subcultures right and
these erotic subcultures often trade not
merely in what we want to do with one
another or to one another but in in the
very particularity of our identities and
i mean that you know in a deeply
intersectional way
white subjects understood or really
offloaded their racialized investments
onto their partners i think of one white
uh man who did race play with his black
partner i am here to help her with her
process of reckoning he said with what
was done by my forefathers to hers right
so
um i'm wondering if i have time to tell
one uh quick story i don't really but i
mean there's so many stories that i
could tell in which um
you know sort of that reproduce this
including um ways in which i was
recruited by subjects to take place in
racialized scenes that forced me to kind
of confront my own articulateness
inarticulateness about what it would
mean for me to do that and i say this
not to collapse into like an erotophobic
discussion about why you know we should
or shouldn't touch research subjects i
have a whole paper on that if you're
interested um
and i have a yes i have a whole paper on
that um but really like struggling with
the provocation made by tiffany king and
many others for those of us working on
issues of social difference from the
position of whiteness to really examine
our investments in racialization or in
avoiding its capture and i was thinking
when shay was talking earlier
that
about about political
experiments beyond restitution that the
interpersonal domain
in a context of trust in a context of
mutuality
is a place where many people are doing
some of these experiments in more just
means of attachment to one another um
and and i think that it that i kind of
want to argue for an agenda that
foregrounds um
what issues of justice require of us
in our most intimate encounters with
others
right and to confront how we're going to
confront these affective and linguistic
failures that so many of us
were enculturated into
but like most things that are worth deep
consideration this is not a new idea in
fact
robert reed far articulated this in 1998
when he wrote quote and i'm going to end
on this idea
what is difficult to accept is the idea
that the sexual act at least it is as it
is performed by queers is not
necessarily a good expansive or
liberatory thing a place in which
individuals exist for a moment outside
of themselves such that new
possibilities are at once imagined and
articulated indeed i'm suggesting that
this notion
is itself predicated upon the
articulation of a set of false
boundaries we do not escape race and
racism when we on the contrary this
fantasy of escape is precisely
that which marks the sexual act as
deeply implicated in the ideological
processes by which difference is
constructed and maintained the task that
awaits all of us then is to speak desire
plainly to pay attention to what we
think when we [ __ ]
more in the it is the particular task of
white men to give up the comforts of
naivete of banal gestures to racial
inclusion indeed the work before us is
precisely to put our own bodies on the
line we must refuse to allow the
production of a queer theory so reified
that it does nothing to challenge the
way we interact the way we think and the
way we [ __ ] we must not only think as we
but also pay close attention to all the
implications good and bad of those
sometimes startling thoughts thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
um thank you all so much that was
terrific um i think we could just move
to uh your questions um i don't think
there's a mic there so maybe i'll run
around with the mic does that yeah okay
uh but i think i'll turn it to you all
if there's that awkward silence i'll go
first wait is that a question yeah
amazing
thank you
um oh
um
i know you were talking about kind of
how to disrupt the violence that occurs
within the home by like bringing grief
into public space i'm interested in a
few or if anyone else's other like
thoughts on how to
yeah and how to disrupt like just the
interpersonal violence that occurs
within the home and like what are other
ways to bring like women who have sex or
like women who are murdered because they
have sex into public space and like what
are the the ideas you have about that or
thoughts
do you want to answer okay
i don't know i did that um
no so this is something that i'm i'm
really still thinking about this is i'm
what three
fifths of the way through the book now
um
so
i'm thinking about community
accountability and about um
what our our own
what our collective responsibility
towards interrupting
violence i think
joe
posed the question about aesthetics i
think that has an important role and my
students have talked
in in really convincing ways about
what the role of art is and in
interrupting rape culture and and
i think
students are most comfortable thinking
that education is the way in which we
have to do
in which we uh
access and put into practice our
collective responsibilities um but it is
something that i'm still thinking
through and i actually would welcome if
the other panelists have something to
say about it but
i am early in thinking
about what this means
i do
uh
yeah i'll just say that that that i i
know
that it's about
us
a line between publicity and privacy
right so i mean playing on the public
private divide and specifically an
intersectional public private divide
where black women have never belonged in
private in the same way that black men
kind of don't belong in public space and
their decision
to to bring the grief into the public
when they didn't have any real private
right is
is an important one and trying to figure
out uh the ways in which to make these
forms of violence more visible is is the
thing that brought me to this project
right and so the fact that
barfield is thinking constantly about
memorialization about statues about
artwork about making people into more
than statistics into making that visible
i think has
something very like is is an important
part of this but it's about
you know i could go off on a whole
tangent about how les moonves was at cbs
and cancel designing women and this like
enter and then put a generation of
murdered women on tv right and and put
that into our visual culture and what it
means that tarana burke has a movie deal
and how i think that that is important
for thinking about um how we interrupt
those kinds of things so those that's my
not quite there yet but the the things
that are moving around in my head about
it thank you
um
i guess this is on uh
yeah i i just wanted to to i appreciate
the question so much and um and your
presentation so much and i really
it made me think a lot about visual
justice especially like the adb wells
image where she inserts herself
in the picture and then brings everybody
who's not in the picture into the fold
and that was so moving
um
and i also i think the question in your
presentation makes me think about black
trans woman being
killed both um in private and in public
and spectacular ways
but despite the kind of spectacle
horrifying spectacle of of that violence
um
there's not the political mobilization
as a response to it and so it
just made me think about that uh until
really recently like
i think it was last summer
i went to a um
black trans pride march in brooklyn
outside of the brooklyn museum
and there were like lit 10 to 15 000
people
and that was unprecedented
which
felt like such a moving
event but
the the like how to sustain that
momentum
um in between the marches
it uh is still like an ongoing like how
to do that you know so um like beyond
visibility basically yeah yeah
yeah i mean
i wrote this down because i think that
there's
so much to think about about um
you know in captive genders where they
talk about the phenomenon of overkill
but no uh no one writes about it right
so
we know that we only find out about
black women being killed when they're
killed in the same news cycle or by the
same departments that kill black men
right and and so uh it follows that it
would be worse in a situation where
there's a suppression of information and
i'm not going to talk about it for black
trans women that you just would not we
won't know so we don't talk about it
right and
but the the moving in the public private
divide is really
is tremendous but i do think
that
you know um
as with stonewall
as with uh
save our sons and daughters right as
with um
you know
antifa right never let a nazi hold the
street right being in the public right
and
decision to occupy public space is a
part of what this is right and and being
there being out right and
is a part of the solution and and so
even if it can't ever be 10 000 or you
know they're only going to be um
sporadic times when it's going to be
that many like it is
thinking about the other ways to keep
us right there is is the thing that
we're fighting for right
hi i'm olivia thanks so much um for your
talk um so listening to all of you speak
has me thinking about um and this
question hasn't been thinking about m
jackie alexander's idea of the
palimpsest right which would have us
think that colonial forms of violence
have an arrangement right of like here
and there and then and now near the
twins shall meet um and it seems like
all of you are kind of invoking the
importance of at least some kind of
palm-cestic way of thinking of we're
thinking about
um here and
here and now and then and there
because i teach many of your works
i'm wondering if you guys can talk about
the kind of pedagogical implications of
this palimpsestic way of thinking or you
know however you choose to interpret the
way that you are all thinking about
historical contingencies
here and there then and now
um for actually kind of
bringing about the various forms of
sexual justice you're invested in um so
i guess a short version of the question
is how does thinking about the sort of
deep histories um in all of your work
um
how does that play a key role in sort of
thinking about um and manifesting an
idea of sexual justice
uh you got i'm gonna take the liberty of
a follow-up which is uh there's a strain
like i said wiki and str eve cedric and
strain of you know the emphasis on the
reparative and not to get caught in the
paranoid right and the kinds of ways
that the paranoid can be circulated so i
just want to i want you to answer that
question i mean but but to think how can
you think the power of cystic
along with uh you know how do you think
the pelletistic and also the reparative
at the same time
i'll leave it there right or is the
pound system is it always kind of a
paranoid turn does it have to be do you
see where i'm going
and okay go go with olivia first yeah
well i i mean
is the word palump i'm so bad at english
you write over and over right right i
think between the mask and my like fear
of my terrible vocabulary i was like is
that the word um i think for me in terms
of pedagogically like you know i teach
at brooklyn college and like
the last few semesters i've
been almost the only white person in the
room so i feel like
i feel like my role in this situation
can be in classes or like intro to
political theory i can try to
historicize sexual injustices
they don't really a lot of those folks
maybe they need details but they don't
need my help historicizing questions of
like structural inequality or histories
of racism so it can be like a
in terms of the mutual conversation
between professor and students and
different locations of privilege it
could be like
really generative but i feel like i
learned more from
being in a room with people who are you
know living in this clinic you know
never-ending colonial moment
in terms of th that informing my own
work on what we're calling today sexual
justice so
yeah i mean i i resonate with that idea
in the sense that part of
the intervention that i think i was
trying to make
is that the idea that
that the current moment isn't always an
overriding of a past is
is really
only a perspective one can hold from a
position of incredible privilege right
and so
there's a way in which i think
you know
students come into classrooms with an
idea of equality
that
is based in identity
for people who
have more of a tangential relationship
to privilege
and based more in a sense of
of a sameness for people who have a
tremendous degree of privilege whether
that's economic privilege gender
privilege racial privilege whatever you
want to say
um and so i think that
i mean
pedagogy has to meet people where they
enter a classroom and move them one step
beyond
where they came in right like that's
what i consider to be a successful uh a
class right is that i've taken somebody
one step beyond their starting point and
people come from very different starting
points
right and so i think on some level
what we have to explain and to whom as
paisley pointed out is really
location dependent
so
my um
so i've participated in a seminar on the
uses of the past
and part of what came out of that for my
thinking was
uh and it's it's in the book
talking about the power that lynching
has on contemporary uh us black politics
and about the ways in which lynching
becomes a way that we talk about things
and the the significance
of that uh for black women so
very few black women relatively were
lynched about five percent according to
your crystal feedster um
and uh
many of them were lynched in place of a
husband father brother that they
couldn't find
um
and so this this means a lot
and this is significant and i think
beyond that
uh to talk about palin says it's the
work that du bois as the best among but
uh but others many others did to connect
lynching and crucifixion right so du
bois has
five six lynching tales where he brings
a black jesus to life in in the jim crow
south he only speaks the words of the
biblical jesus christ this indicts
everything that goes on and he dies for
it
um and i think that
those mar the martyr themes right the
resurrective work the
things that are going on are a powerful
story you know and i've said like a
former person here uh roger smith who's
not here anymore uh it's important in
the story of black peoplehood and part
of what uh black women are gonna have to
do
uh
is uh tell a new story right because
this is a rewriting rewriting over and
over again
um
what do we do
that black men took the climax of the
bible but luckily we have cedia hartman
and toni morrison and others from whom
that we can think about how to deal with
with these kinds of deaths and ungrieved
deaths
but that's going to be the way to write
a
new story to stop writing over the past
and think about how to put one
at least
on a
equal footing
for thinking about the the origins of
our politics
thank you so much for that question and
i
i
felt really like
transformed i guess i would say by
reading pedagogies of crossing and so i
um always feel like yeah like jack
alexander's work
um
is like a condition of possibility for
my own thinking and i feel very indebted
to her labors critical labors conceptual
labors um
and
i guess i
your question makes me think about
how to have an abolitionist pedagogy
both inside the university classroom and
what that might mean um as a worker in
the university
um
and also inside the space of of the
prison
and like you know what does an
abolitionist pedagogy look like
when you're teaching inside and outside
um
and
uh
it also you know
i showed some of well an image from
tourmaline's films alicia
and you know she really like folds time
and folds space
and i think part of what that does is
like
show the ruse of of racial liberal
progress narratives that would tell us
that like
for example cross-dressing is
decriminalized
when it's not in prisons right so i
think that like showing the foil of this
um
teleological
kind of racial liberal
um
uh time zone uh it is like part of what
pimple says
now i'm like mispronounced holy spirit
part of what that project does
um and i think that that is crucial to
uh part of the demystification work that
an abolitionist pedagogy
can uh offer canon does often so thanks
i think maybe one more question
i feel like it's close to seven okay
great
yeah hi there oh that's loud i'm
i'm gabby thank you so much for for
coming to speak with us and
as you were all talking i was thinking a
lot about
sexual injustice beyond questions of
consent
you know like the unjust formation of
one's sexual proclivities and
preferences sexual racism etc
and i
am curious to hear from any of you how
we should approach talking about how
desire has a politics
and you know talking about ways to
individually and collectively reckon
with that politics
without sliding into what you know
sort of sex positivity advocates would
call like prudish or authoritarian
sexual moralizing
you want to take that one on uh
you know i mean
i mean look
it's it's
you know there are a lot of sociologists
right now that have been working on on
sexual racism right and and
and i think that there are these sort of
two formulations one is that
um
that
the intimate realm
is a place where
you know it functions as a marketplace
right so that's that's often how
sociologists think about it right that
that that
that there is something called the
sexual field in a bordusian sense in
which you know different people because
of what they look like and their social
position have different amounts of
erotic capital and this functions in you
know in very predictable ways to
disadvantage uh women people of color
people who don't fit you know sort of
hegemonic standards of beauty and so
forth and that that is
the the route from which
we need to begin to politicize desire
like what does it mean to you know i
mean it's sort of like
um
like there's there's like a
website called douchebags of grinder
right for example where it's just like
basically like all the men's profiles
were like no fats no femmes no blacks
you know like those people and as if as
if
they are
uh
an individual level problem
right whereas um
the
the
the actual problem
of desire is so much deeper
than
bad behavior
done publicly by one person right we are
all complicit in structures of desire
that disadvantage like you know it's
kind of like you know when when when
my mother wants to give my daughter
lessons about sexuality which i really
never want her to do ever
and she's just like date the nice boy
but the truth is she means like the nice
handsome you know boy who's gonna be a
doctor right like that's what she means
um my daughter has come out as straight
you know we're we're processing it in
therapy i'm hoping
i'm hoping you know she'll get over it
at some point but um because
heterosexuality these days seems as jane
ward says fairly tragic but um
another panel uh but but i do think that
we that that that we need to that the
first step
in
um having a different conception of
desire and i i really i hate this
masculinist
economic framework for understanding
desire because i think that it's like
you know like everybody some people have
got a thicker wallet of desirability
than others and i just think that like
that that desire um is is so much more
of a
uh
god multivalent phenomenon but i do
think that we are all complicit in
reproducing structures of desire and
desirability both in our presentations
of self in the ways in which we value or
devalue other people even in terms of
like i hope he's a doctor right like
that is also a structure of desire and
it's one that doesn't
really account for it's a it's a sort of
it's a cruel optimism as lauren berlant
would say right like you that you
imagine who the perfect partner is going
to be and oftentimes that perfect
partner is someone that you enter into
like a completely miserable marriage
with right and so really thinking about
what are the things that make people
desirable both erotically right and
maybe it's something like they know what
they're doing in bed right that would be
nice i mean i'd like to see the the
the app that that kind of tries to get
at that algorithmically um if if you
know of it you know my email is
available online like but it you know so
i i mean i think that part of it is is
understanding our own investments
in
particular forms of partnership
particular forms of erotic engagement um
as being part and parcel of
an overall
kind of uh
right like a structure of affect right
touch
okay i think i think we're set one last
round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
you